[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descende des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés nous sommes cousins
germains maternelle qui était bretonne
me disais si toi tu es descendu sa joie
sur rampe a révélé nous un secret vous
en avez mangé du mammouth je me trouve à
fouiller en sibérie et puis un beau
matin dans le trou que j'avais commencé
à creuser je trouve que les troupes
comme c'est quelque chose de bien les
grands filaments je suis étonnée je râle
je dirais que ce sont des collègues
russes qui sont venus tripatouiller le
fond de ma recherche et puis à force de
tirer dessus comme rien ne venait je me
suis aperçu que j'étais sur le dos
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur rt france pour une heure
et demie d'émission comme chaque jour du
lundi au jeudi jusqu'à 21h30 place au
décryptage les grands titres de
l'actualité de la journée au sommaire de
ce jeudi 9 décembre
réformer les accords de schengen définit
une souveraineté stratégiques
européennes repenser le cadre budgétaire
continental autant d'axés prioritaires
présenté cet après-midi par emmanuel
macron en vue de la présidence française
du conseil de l'union européenne qui
débute le 1er janvier une tribune face à
100 journalistes que certains jugent
électoraliste et que d'autres qualifient
d' aubaine à quatre mois des élections
présidentielles on attend vos réactions
sur le conte télégramme tard défense
leur offre également à l'agenda de joe
biden après avoir échangé cette semaine
avec ses homologues russe vladimir
poutine et ukrainien volodimir zielinski
le président américain s'entretiendra ce
soir avec les dirigeants des neuf de
bucarest un groupe composé des alliés de
l'otan du flanc oriental européens ont
tenu des discussions notamment le
dossier ukrainien et sur l'or que le
locataire de la maison blanche
réunissant dix pays et territoires de
façon virtuelle sur deux jours pour
l'évoquer est la démocratie made in you
et c'est
alors que le plan blanc pourrait être
activée dans tous les hôpitaux au niveau
national selon le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand la cinquième vague de
communes 19 continue d'inquiéter pour
l'instant cette région ont déclenché le
dispositif qui permet entre autres de
déprogrammer des opérations non urgentes
un rebond épidémique avec notamment
l'apparition du variant omicron qui
inquiète les marchés financiers à
l'heure où les restrictions sanitaire se
multiplient en europe doit-on
s'inquiéter pour 2022 c'est l'édito tout
à l'heure de notre mr jacques sapir
une flopée de nom ce matin de la part
des candidats de la gauche à la
présidentielle au lendemain de la
proposition d'anne hidalgo la candidate
socialiste suggère une primaire l'idée
ne séduit pas ses homologues écologistes
insoumis ou communistes et ce alors que
l'ensemble des candidats de gauche
totalisent seulement 25% des intentions
de vote dans les récents sondages la
gauche at-elle encore une chance pour
avril prochain on attend en retour sur
le télégramme daté france
j mois à 23 avant le 1er janvier date du
début de la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne une
première depuis 2008 l'occasion pour
emmanuel macron de détailler ses
priorités pour le vieux continent lors
d'une longue conférence de presse cet
après midi au palais de l'élysée devant
lequel se trouve guimard haussier
qui m'a beaucoup de journalistes pour un
exercice rare
[Musique]
oui tout à fait et grégory un rare c'est
le mot c'est la deuxième fois seulement
qu emmanuel macron se prêtait à cet
échange avec les journalistes avec la
presse française un échange de plus de
deux heures alors pad annonce de
candidature cela dit on n'y croyait pas
trop le chef de l'état s'est concentrée
sur la présidence française du conseil
de l'union européenne la treizième
présidence semestrielle française la
dernière fois c'était en 2008 et qui
devrait donc être l'occasion pour la
france de pousser dans une certaine
direction les politiques européennes il
marie emmanuelle macron a défini
plusieurs axes 1 pour la présidence
française du conseil de l'ue
mais oui tout à fait grégory ils sont
nombreux ces actes cette conférence de
presse à d'ailleurs commencé par la
présentation l'annnonce de la mise en
circulation d'une nouvelle pièce de deux
euros une histoire de marquer le coup
pour les 20 ans de la monnaie commune au
delà de cette annonce symbolique le chef
de l'état a déroulé ses ambitions pour
cette présidence française un new deal
pour l'afrique pour commencer pour je
cite refonder la relation un peu fatigué
entre les deux continents le président
veut également instaurer un service
civique européen de six mois pour les
moins de 25 ans il a également proposé
de repenser le cadre budgétaire européen
estimant que l'éternel pour ou contre
les 3% de déficit était un peu dépassée
et il ambitionne même de faire de
l'europe une puissance numérique gregory
j on a entendu d'autres priorités
guillemin formulée par le président qui
elles font écho à la campagne
présidentielle française
mais oui tout à fait et grégory
notamment sur le thème de l'europe d'une
europe puissante emmanuel macron plus
que jamais prêt européen veut définir
durant cette présidence française je
cite une souveraineté stratégiques
européennes écouter
s'il fallait résumer en une phrase
l'objectif de cette présidence qui
s'étendra du 1er janvier au 30 juin je
dirais que nous devons passer d'une
europe de coopération à l'intérieur de
nos frontières à une europe puissante
dans le monde pleinement souveraine
libre de ses choix et maître de son
destin et c'est ça l'objectif c'est ce
que nous préparons déjà vous savez
depuis plusieurs années le profondément
transformé notre organisation de nous
doter d'une ambition nouvelle
j'avais eu l'occasion de présenter cet
agenda dès l'automne 2010 est à la
sorbonne et nous avons déjà parachever
beaucoup des objectifs qui avaient été
alors annoncée alors cette ambition elle
n'est pas à neuf on a souvent entendu
emmanuel macron sur cette thématique
notamment sur l'europe de la défense
mais ses déclarations
elles font écho à celles de valérie
pécresse la mieux placé dans les
sondages derrière emmanuel macron elle a
plaidé dans une tribune au journal le
monde pour un renforcement de l'europe
l'europe qui selon la candidate heller
défendent est une civilisation qui
jouait son destin dans un monde
dangereux à un argumentaire qui vient
frôler un petit peu celui d'un eric
zemmour eric zemmour qui lui se place en
rempart de l'immigration est justement
quelques minutes ont été accordés à
l'immigration par emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui écoutés nous initierons sous
cette présidence une réforme de l'espace
schengen autour de deux priorités
la première ce sera la mise en place
d'un pilotage politique de schengen de
pouvoir avoir des réunions régulières de
prendre des décisions politiques de
pouvoir renforcer les contrôles aux
frontières et d'avoir une politique
cohérente de maîtrise
de nos frontières extérieures
deuxièmement
souhaitons porter la création d'un
mécanisme de soutien d'urgence aux
frontières en cas de crise quand un état
membre doit soudainement faire face à
une crise qui exigent de renforcer le
contrôle aux frontières extérieures de
notre union comme nous l'avons vécu
encore une fois récemment il doit
pouvoir compter sur l'appui de frontex
agence
commune dont c'est la vocation mais
également le renfort solidaire des états
membres en policiers gendarmes comme en
matériel mais manuel macron souhaite
également initié un grand travail sur
l'histoire de l'europe pour lutter
contre les révisionnistes mais ce
faisant il se place en adversaire des
nationalismes en europe mais également
en france bref emmanuel macron à
déployer son programme européen devant
les journalistes exercice rare je le
répète à quatre mois de la
présidentielle quelques jours seulement
après l'investiture de valérie pécresse
et l' annonce de la candidature d'eric
zemmour cela n'a rien d'anodin
d'ailleurs on le voyait bien dans nos
bureaux on pouvait voir le visage du
président sur toutes les chaînes c'est
ce qui s'appelle occuper l'espace
médiatique et dans une campagne
officielle ou non c'est bien pratique
merci guillemets en rosit pour vos
précisions direct de l'elysée merci
également à sébastien dufour qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra devant
le palais de l'elysée dont il ya quatre
mois de l'élection présidentielle ce
calendrier européen est-il une aubaine
pour le chef de l'état ou bien est-il un
fardeau difficile à porter présidence
française du conseil de l'ue à une
nouvelle tribune pour emmanuel macron on
attend vos avis sur le conte télégramme
daté france tout de suite c'est le débat
est ce soir en direct pour évoquer ce
débat deux invités
d'un côté jean bizet
ancien sénateur les républicains de la
manche et ex président de la commission
des affaires européennes au sénat à vos
côtés il y à jean paul garraud député du
rassemblement national membre du bureau
de campagne présidentielle de marine le
pen et puis sur ce plateau claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonjour messieurs je
commence directement avec vous jean
bizet emmanuel macron souhaite définir
une phrase c'est une souveraineté
stratégiques européennes mais est-ce
qu'on peut être souverain à 27
oui bien sûr parce qu'un certain nombre
de dossiers précisément une dimension
européenne
et il a bien évoqué au travers du
triptyque puissance relancer et
appartenance je crois que ceci est tout
à fait complémentaires claude
blanchemaison en évoque pourtant souvent
une souveraineté d'un état quand on voit
les divergences de l'union européenne
que ce soit sur le cadre budgétaire on
l'a vu dans le plan de relance entre les
pays du nord les pays dits frugaux les
pays du sud on l'a vu également avec la
question migratoire la répartition des
flux migratoires souvent source de
litige les divergences juridique
également avec la pologne la hongrie
face au couple franco allemand notamment
est ce qu'on peut se mettre d'accord à
27 c vraiment possible c'est difficile
c'est sûr c'est plus difficile à reims
est que lorsque nous étions 6 au début
de la communauté européenne quoique à
l'époque le général de gaulle avait fait
la politique de la chaise vide pendant
six mois pour obtenir la mise en oeuvre
de la politique agricole commune donc
c'était déjà difficile à 6 au fur et à
mesure d'élargissement c'est devenu plus
difficile mais on y arrive la preuve
c'est que il ya quatre ans ou cinq ans
il aurait été inimaginable de parler
d'un plan de 750 milliards d'euros pour
relancer l'économie après les ravages
faits par le la pandémie du but d'hugo
vide 19 et pourtant cela s'est fait et
pourtant les allemands ont changé de
positions ont évolué ont fait preuve de
réalisme madame merkel a en effet vu
quelles étaient les les conséquences
qu'elle était la situation et elle s'est
laissé convaincre de
demander à la commission de mettre en
place ce plan qui a été mis en place
alors bien sûr dont on peut se mettre
d'accord mais en terme de souveraineté
quand on est souvent généralement en
hessel mais là il ya d'autres donc on y
est ce qu'on n'est pas un peu dépendant
encore une fois le général de gaulle a
imposé la politique agricole commune
parce qu'il voulait qu'il y ait cette
politique est effectivement la
négociation se fait souvent avec des
passages très tendue avec des crises
même mais l'union européenne n'a
progressé qu'à travers des crises et à
chaque fois on a fini par trouver une
solution qui tienne compte des
préoccupations essentielles de chacun
des états alors évidemment quand on les
27 on peut pas tenir compte des
préoccupations tout le monde mais il ya
une règle du jeu qui veut que si un état
membre 6 1 un chef d'état ou de
gouvernement un problème essentiel vital
sur le plan politique pour lui eh bien
on en tient compte jean paul garraud je
me tourne vers vous et emmanuel macron
souhaite réformer les accords de
schengen et renforcer le contrôle aux
frontières extérieures mais il n'a pas
évoqué la répartition des flux
migratoires souvent source de litige est
ce que c'est pas voulu ça comme on l'a
entendu guillemard aussi notre reporter
devant le palais de l'elysée il ya la
campagne présidentielle et l'immigration
c'est un thème très important dans cette
campagne
avec notamment marine le pen que vous
soutenez ou encore un exe moins
bien sûr mais il y à une contradiction
manifeste d'un scan dit que le président
de la république il indique vouloir
renforcer je dirais le contrôle aux
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne il avait une bonne occasion
de le faire avec malheureusement ce qui
s'est passé avec la pologne avec la
hongrie avec la lettonie la lituanie qui
sont face à quasiment les maisons
d'invasion migratoires qui comme la
grèce d'ailleurs pas la peine d'attendre
la mise en place de mécanismes pour
aider à défendre nos frontières
extérieures il faut les défendre et il
faut les défendre dès à présent et bien
entendu la france aurait pu s'honorer à
aller porter secours à la pologne par
rapport à ce qu'elle connut est-ce
qu'elle a connue et c'est connaît
d'ailleurs encore dans si vous voulez ya
une contradiction pourquoi ils annoncent
un mécanisme concernant chaque guen pour
en fait essayer d'aller vers une défense
des frontières en réalité il ne le fera
pas parce qu'il pourrait déjà le faire
donc le premier point ensuite monsieur
macron bien sûr est en campagne nous le
savons bien c'est une tribune pour la
bonne raison d'ailleurs que il lui
aurait été tout à fait possible de
reporter la présidence donc de l'union
européenne ils pouvaient le faire il va
en faire la demande au conseil européen
il ne l'a pas fait il ne l'a pas fait
parce que ça lui donne une tribune
or il n'est pas sérieux me semble utile
d'avoir autant d'actions prévues ne
flottait une sorte de grand messe
d'aude à la gloire de la souveraineté
européenne pendant ces six mois alors
qu'on est en même temps c'est le propre
d'ailleurs de la caractéristique de
monsieur macron d'être en même temps
candidat donc à l'élection
présidentielle et la résidence la
ritaline et nature un oui mais nous le
savons bien ressort bien qu'il est qu'il
sera candidat naturellement il le dira
en dernier moment tant qu'ils s'offrent
générer une tribune avait il manie à la
fois des thèmes récurrents chez lui
parce que si vous voulez moi je ne
comprends pas une chose il faudra qu'on
m'explique pour que l'europe soit forte
il faut que les nations qui composent
l'europe soit forte ça me semble logique
or avant de penser à finalement tout une
sorte de politique
ambitieuse pour l'afrique je
souhaiterais d'abord quand renforce
évidemment les possibilités de notre
pays et des pays européens
après tout avant de faire une politique
pour l'afrique essayons de faire une
politique entre européenne pour la
france et parce que là j'ai noté aussi
une dissociation alors totale entre
finalement ses objectifs très ambitieux
très mondialisé je dirais de monsieur
macro et les réalités quotidiennes de
notre pays qui sont très difficiles à
vivre et quand il parle enfin de ^ ^ oui
mais quelle impuissance au contraire
l'europe a fait preuve notamment au
cours de la crise bien sûr du vide on va
pas refaire l'histoire on le sait bien
et puis naturellement par rapport à tout
ce problème li grattoir qu'il n'avait qu
il a juste esquissé six volets il faut
quand même il n'a pas parlé du parc
national international pardon européen
sur l'asile et l'immigration où on va
voir arriver une soixantaine de millions
de migrants avec une répartition
automatique dans les pays membres de
l'union européenne tout ceci bien
entendu il n'a pas parlé donc si vous
voulez il y à laquelle nombreuses
fonctions mais enfin pendant longtemps
vous parlez un peu longtemps aussi je
vais donner la parole à adjamé des cas
très certainement envie de vous et je
vous de vous répondre
écoutez je ne fais pas d'accord avec ce
que dit effectivement monsieur gare aux
dés dans la rhétorique habituelle du
rassemblement national
par contre si vous voulez moi je salue
la décision du président macro de
s'investir pour l'afrique et là il
reprend en quelque sorte l'un politique
qu'avait initié
nicolas sarkozy avec l'union pour la
méditerranée une politique que
malheureusement à l'époque la
chancelière merkel n'avait pas voulu je
dirais accepté et s'engager si ç'avait
été le cas et bien nous serions sans
doute pas là si vous voulez dans la
grosse problématique est celle de
l'immigration il n'y a pas que
l'immigration qui vient du continent
africain
mais c'était si on ne veut pas si on ne
veut pas se charger de regarder ce qu'il
y a au delà de la méditerranée
nous aurons je dirais un avenir
difficile en ce qui concerne la défense
je dirais des des frontières et la
revisitation de schengen c'est pas
nouveau ce qu'annonçait le présent la
république en fin de compte le puzzle
existe déjà simplement un certain nombre
d'états je dirais hésitent à faire appel
à frontex dans notre agence qui a pour
but de défendre nos premières de
frontières agences de gardes côtes
européennes
absolument oui nous avons déjà mis
beaucoup d'argent chez frontex dans ce
contexte tout le puzzle est prêt
simplement si vous voulez sa mise en
oeuvre quelquefois un petit peu délicate
si vous voulez faire venir des matériels
des hommes pour défendre des frontières
dans d'autres états membres à mon avis
c'est un pas qu'il faut franchir et
c'est une gestion comme la ville prada
république je suis pas chargé de le
défendre jacquin scemama sensibilités
politiques mais si vous voulez il faut
désormais une vraie gestion politique de
schengen et une plus grande réactivité
de l'europe en la matière
vous n'avez pas répondu sur l'une des
questions c'est jean paul garraud il a
dit que le président était en tribunes
jean bizet un journaliste a demandé à
emmanuel macron s'il ne jouait pas sur
les mots présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne epa présidence de
l'union européenne donc est ce que c'est
une tribune électorale ou pas une
tribune électorale ce qui le monopolise
l'espace médiatique comme l'a dit guy
mais aussi devant le palais de deux de
l'élysée comment est ce que vous voyez
ça sans parler du technique
disons que la présidence française de
l'union arrive précisément
concomitamment avec la réélection du
printemps la république ce n'est pas
illégal 2 ce n'est pas prémédité 3 c'est
vrai par contre ce qu'a dit monsieur
garrot il aurait pu demander le report
de cette présidence il ne l'a pas fait
certes c'est à lui donne une tout certes
mais les traits les sujets qu'ils
traitent des sujets cl d'hier du
quotidien as peut-être parce qu'à la
présidence je me paraît de vous couper
la présidence est tournante elle dure
six mois
las il rentre en campagne l'élection
présidentielle c'est en avril il va
devoir arrêter de président et non
qu'est ce qui va se passer techniquement
est ce que la france va présider
concrètement six mois non la france
présidera essentiellement pendant trois
mois c'est une évidence mais d'autres
pays ont eu ce type d'exercice elles
n'ont réussi c'est une occasion
également extraordinaire pour la france
est bien de faire passer un certain
nombre de messages au moment précisément
où nous avons l'émergence d'une nouvelle
coalition allemande et moi je retiens un
point qui n'a pas encore été évoquée par
les deux autres collègues c'est que le
prêt en la république ne s'interdirait
pas si je finir d'aller jusqu'à engagé
la révision des traités européens
il reprend je dirais la main de ce que
récemment proposé le chancelier le
changerai de les shops donc on va assez
loin moi je pense que c'est une
opportunité pour monsieur macro certes
mais si tu es nous partis dîner était
également pour l'union européenne
d'avoir un pays tel que la france en ce
moment et bien de porter un certain
nombre de dossiers importants jean paul
garraud a regardé cette réaction sur le
compte rt france 2 de thé sur le
contraire tu es france de télégrammes
salon body on ne parle jamais de cette
présidence tournante qui lui semblent
honorifique je suis incapable de dire
qu'il occupe actuellement je ne pense
pas que cela soit la préoccupation
majeure du pays actuellement est ce
qu'on en fait pas un peu trop votre
réaction jean paul garraud d'ailleurs ce
que vous savez qui est actuellement
président du conseil de l'union
européenne
bien sûr puisque en fait et c'est cette
personne a tout à fait raison
puisque nous savons bien que la
présidente sortante 10 une présidence
slovène et je défie quiconque ici et
ailleurs enfin à part bien sûr les
intervenants sur ce plateau de nous dire
vraiment quel est le résultat de cette
présidence slovène donc ce qui me fait
dire effectivement que nous sommes
complètement et que le président vaincre
on est complètement décalé des réalités
de terrain je crois juste un point par
rapport à monsieur visé je suis pas du
tout dans une rhétorique que lui
rassemblement national ceci est facile à
dire non j'ai toujours eu les mêmes
idées je ne suis pas à la différence de
6 10 et macro compatibles c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je suis parti
donc des républicains donc non
simplement j'étudie un certain nombre de
sujets moi je suis pour une france forte
à l'intérieur d'une europe qui pourra
l'être aussi à partir du moment où il y
aura des nations fortes et puis si vous
voulez il ya aussi de nombreuses
contradictions dans ce qu'a dit le
président la république des
contradictions entre ce qu'il dit est ce
qu'il fait parce que quand les députés
de la république en marche qui
appartiennent à au groupe donc au
parlement européen renault quand ils
votent et ben ils votent pas du tout si
vous voulez dans le sens de certaines
propositions que j'ai entendu dans la
bouche du président de la république et
ils votent par exemple contre la pole au
niveau me contre la hongrie qui défendra
les frontières extérieures de l'europe
savez vous que actuellement douze pays
membres de l'union européenne douze pays
c'est à rien sur vingt-sept demandent
l'aide de la commission européenne pour
qu on met malheureusement je dirais mais
on ne peut pas faire autrement parce
qu'on est dans l'urgence pour qu'on
mettre des barrières pour commettre des
clôtures pour éviter l'invasion
migratoire à qui est en cours ces douze
pays membres de l'union européenne
réclament cette aide est bien sûr la
commission européenne la refuse or ces
nations elles sont souveraines elles
n'ont pas à être mise au ban de l'europe
parce que derrière le discours de
monsieur macron il y à vous savez tout
ce qui est national nisme révisionnisme
etc il y à cette idéologie qui fait d'un
côté des gentils de l'autre côté les
méchants d'un côté l'ombre dans le côté
la lumière oui alors ça le sens où on
l'apprend l'a bien compris je me tourne
vers claude blanchou maisons closes
emmanuel macron s'entretient demain avec
olaf scholz le nouveau chancelier
allemand il doit également s'entretenir
la semaine prochaine avec le président
russe vladimir poutine ils seront aussi
lundi en hongrie pour discuter avec
viktor orban la politique étrangère est
ce que ça intéresse les français au
moment où il ya l'élection
présidentielle qui arrive peut-être
moins que en effet certains éléments de
politique intérieure et notamment le
pouvoir d'achat la politique de
migration mais néanmoins lorsque les
choses ont mal en politique extérieure
et bien c'est porter au débit du
président et et en 2008 lorsque la
dernière présidence française si on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure et bien
malheureusement au mois d'août au tout
début de présidence française du
deuxième semestre a éclaté la guerre en
géorgie et le président sarkozy a pris
l'initiative de faire la navette entre
moscou et tbilissi pour obtenir un
cessez-le-feu parce que c'était
l'urgence et aucun autre état membre n'a
objecté il n'avait aucun mandat pour le
faire il avait un mandat tacite si j'ose
dire et dans le fond puisqu'il a réussi
et bien tout le monde a approuvé sa
démarche alors tout ce qu'il dit ou
double enfin pardon ça peut être un
quitte ou double oui alors pour ce qui
est du choix du nouveau chancelier
allemand il était évidemment aux
ministres des finances deux du
gouvernement précédent il ya donc une
continuité avec toutefois une inflexion
c'est que ce gouvernement qui comporte
des libéraux et des verts est plus
européen que le précédent et on le voit
en lisant leur programme de gouvernement
puisque pendant deux mois ils ont
négocié ligne à ligne un très épais
programme de gouvernement et on voit
bien que monsieur sol s'il vient à paris
pour
comptait sur la présidence française de
ce semestre pour faire un certain nombre
de relance européenne alors bien sûr
c'est pas très pratique parce qu'il ya
ces élections qui interviennent au mois
de mai et bien en effet juridiquement
c'est la france qui exerce la présidence
pendant six mois et s'il devait arriver
que quelqu'un d'autre soit élu à la
présidence de la république au mois de
mai gagnées l'achèverait la présidence
française comment j'y viens j'y viens
jean bizet ya lucien blanc qui nous dit
sur télégramme comment emmanuel macron
peut prétendre devenir le président de
l'union européenne alors qu'il ne sera
peut-être pas le président de la france
mais c'est qu'on rappelle ans et une
présidence tournante vous l'avait bien
dit et il aurait pu refuser il aurait pu
reporter mais il quand même cette
question est intéressante votre réaction
oui mais comme l'a dit tout à l'heure
monsieur blanchemaison la république
perdurera et achèvera ce qu'a commencé
monsieur macro il n'ya rien
d'irrationnel en la matière si vous
voulez c'est tout votre réaction jean
paul garraud
moi je dis simplement que
conciliables mais monsieur macron il
veut faire de l'union européenne un état
un état véritablement supra nationale il
veut faire de l'union européenne une
souveraineté d'ailleurs il veut créer
une culture européenne il me forget tout
ceci une histoire européenne il parle de
souveraineté européenne nous sommes
profondément opposé à cela nous sommes
pour une europe mais une europe des
nations et de nation forte à l'intérieur
de l'europe qui respecte les identités
qui respecte nos civilisations la
l'union européenne n'est pas un état et
ne peut pas être un état ça s'éteint une
différence qui fonda à l'idée d'une
europe fédérale
à ballon jeune je mets le traité en
attendant le traité de rome de 1957
demande je peux vous assurer d'une chose
c'est que le général de gaulle aurait
absolument refuser qu'il y ait de
souveraineté au delà au dessus de la
souveraineté française bien entendu des
accords de coopération entre états
robert schuman qui
étaient là bien sûr mais est bien sûr
mais vous savez ça va passer on repart
outre passé la volonté du général de
gaulle qui a beaucoup contribué bien sûr
à la construction européenne notamment
avec le chancelier adenauer à l'époque
donc si vous voulez il est bien clair il
est bien clair qu'il n'est pas question
de souveraineté européenne et que je je
considère d'ailleurs que l'union
européenne ne peut pas être un état
c'est ce qui nous différencie
fondamentalement avec la vision
mondialisée et on a vu ce que ça a donné
avec la crise du coc vite notamment ou
l'impuissance de l'union européenne a
été dramatique pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens
rapidement le mot de la fin jean bizet
très rapidement c'est la fin
écoutez puisque le monsieur garraud a
parlé de la crise qu vide moi j'ai quand
même je voudrais quand même constater
que l'union européenne est aujourd'hui
le continent qui aura permis d'acquérir
et d'utiliser un stock de vaccins
qu'aucun état membre n'aurait pu inviter
individuellement faire et parler de
souveraineté européenne
comment peut-on imaginer si je puis dire
le poids des différents états membres
pris individuellement par rapport au
poids d'un continent qui est celui de
l'union tél
aujourd'hui si nous n'avons pas de
souveraineté européenne si nous
n'affirmons pas la souveraineté et la
puissance de l'europe eh bien nous nous
serons que des nains face aux états unis
et à la chine merci jean bizet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci également
jean-paul garraud d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien sénateur et l'air de la manche
ancien président de la commission des
affaires européennes au sénat pour l'un
et eurodéputé rassemblement national et
membre du bureau de campagne
présidentielle de marine le pen pour
l'autre merci également à boucles
blanchemaison vous êtes expert en
relations internationales
la france bientôt donc à la tête du
conseil de l'ue eux pour six mois une
période durant laquelle il y aura les
jeux olympiques d'hiver de pékin en
février un événement boycotter
diplomatiquement par washington londres
canberra ou encore ottawa suivi les
états ont suivi les états unis paris
marque sa différence et a annoncé ce
matin il participe et diplomatiquement
tout comme le secrétaire général de
l'onu ce soir antonio guterres s matière
remaniant
londres et ottawa suivent washington et
canberra le royaume uni et le canada
n'en verront pas leurs diplomates aux
jeux olympiques d'hiver à pékin tout
comme les états-unis l'australie ou
encore la nouvelle landes c'était
affirme vouloir faire pression sur la
chine sur la question des droits humains
je ne pense pas que la décision du
canada où de nombreux autres pays de
choisir d'une pas envoyé de
représentation diplomatique aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de pékin va
surprendre la chine nous avons été très
clairs au cours des dernières années de
nos profondes inquiétudes concernant les
violations des droits de l'homme et
c'est la continuité de nos inquiétudes
concernant ces violations a continué
mais ce boycott est uniquement
diplomatique les sportifs eux
participeront bien au jeu de quoi
susciter les railleries de pékin qui a
répondu sèchement aux annonces de
l'australie et des états unis
la chine a invité aucun représentant du
gouvernement australien aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver de pékin tout le
monde se fiche de savoir s'ils viennent
ou non leur politique politicienne et
leur petit jeu ne changeront en rien la
réussite et jeux olympiques de beijing
au métier nous avons déjà dit que les
etats-unis paieront l'entrée de leurs
mauvais coups pour tout le reste est
light pas d'accueil ce moniteur fidèle à
lui-même le comité international
olympique évoque le principe de
neutralité politique et refuse de réagir
ou de prendre position oui enfin il faut
le focus
nous nous concentrons entièrement sur
les athlètes les athlètes sont au centre
des jeux et les jeux sont pour les
athlètes et donc vous entendrez le même
commentaire de notre part pour chaque
décision politique de n'importe quel
gouvernement
nous nous sommes préoccupés des athlètes
nous nous réjouissons qu'ils puissent
participer et qu'ils soient soutenus par
leurs gouvernements nationaux
le reste est politique et nous
appliquons le principe de neutralité
politique
la france de son côté a annoncé ce jeudi
matin qu'elle ne boycotterai pas les jo
d'hiver à pékin sur le plan diplomatique
place aujourd'hui et demain au sommet
pour la démocratie une promesse de
campagne du président américain joe
biden 110 pays et territoires sont
virtuellement réunis et la liste des
invités triés par la maison blanche fait
débat entre tout de suite notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnin
thomas le choix de mettre certains pays
de côté pose la question des véritables
intentions de washington
oui et c'est donc dans un climat de
défiance que s'est ouvert ce sommet pour
la démocratie parce que comme vous
l'avez dit il y a des doutes sur les
réelles intentions américaines c'est ce
qu'ont exprimé notamment moscou et pékin
qui comme vous le savez ne sont pas
conviés à cet événement avec donc des
sérieuses interrogations sur la posture
américaine est ce que finalement les
états unis ne se transformerait pas en
distributeur de bons et de mauvais
points à l'égard des pays du monde alors
la maison blanche s'en défend mais c'est
bien l'impression qu'on un certain
nombre de pays notamment ceux qui n'ont
pas été conviés alors dans son discours
d'ouverture aujourd'hui joe biden et a
reconnu lui même est les problèmes
auxquels font face la démocratie
américaine écoutez un extrait de son
discours
cela fait longtemps que je réfléchisse à
cet événement pour une raison simple
face à des défis importants et
inquiétants pour la démocratie et les
droits humains universels à travers le
monde ait la démocratie a besoin de
champions
et je voulais organiser ce sommet car
ici aux etats unis nous savons aussi
bien que quiconque que renouveler la
démocratie et renforcer nos institutions
démocratiques demande un effort constant
joe biden qui a également profité de ce
discours pour vanter les mesures prises
par son administration à l'échelle
nationale il a également fixé les
grandes thématiques qu'il souhaite voir
abordés lors de ce sommet pour la
démocratie il a également fait la
promotion des valeurs américaines en
matière de démocratie mais donc ce
sommet se tient dans un climat de
scepticisme y compris de la part d'un
certain nombre de médias américains qui
en plus de remettre en question les
invitations adressées par la maison
blanche et même certains doutes sur les
réelles engagement qui pourraient être
pris lors de ce sommet alors parmi les
thèmes qui ont déjà été abordés la lutte
contre la corruption ou encore la
liberté d'information qui est d'ailleurs
eu un tweet du secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken dans lequel il
exprimait ses regrets sur le fait que
des journalistes soient emprisonnés dans
le monde et il a subi un retour de bâton
sur les réseaux sociaux puisque
évidemment beaucoup de personnes lui ont
répondu que julian assange était lui
aussi en prison au royaume uni et qu'il
faisait toujours face à une demande
d'extradition de la part de la justice
américaine d'ailleurs l'ironie du
calendrier fait que c'est demain que la
cour d'appel britannique va rendre sa
décision ce qui concerne le lanceur
d'alertés citoyens vous parler de
calendrier joe biden à un call est à un
calendrier chargé puisqu'il a décidé de
s'investir pleinement dans le dossier
ukrainien
will continue de débriefer son entretien
en visioconférence avec vladimir poutine
il a appelé il ya quelques instants le
président ukrainien volodimir zielinski
pour évoquer avec lui précisément la
présence de militaires russes le long de
la frontière et puis un autre appel est
prévu pour le locataire de la maison
blanche avec le groupe des 9 de bucarest
il s'agit de neuf pays d'europe de l'est
membres de l'otan et la maison blanche
indique vouloir souligner l'engagement
américain en matière de sécurité
transatlantique
merci thomas bonnet pour toutes vos
précisions en direct de washington et
pour le président français cette
intervention des états unis dans le
dossier ukrainien ne change pas les voix
de discussion prioritaire un rappel cet
après-midi d'emmanuel macron lors de sa
conférence de presse le chef de l'état
français et qui fait référence au format
de négociations divine normandie entre
la france l'allemagne la russie et
l'ukraine cabaye donne on le rappelle
menace ces derniers jours de sanctionner
lourdement moscou en cas d'invasion de
l'ukraine est aujourd'hui à la
diplomatie russe a une nouvelle fois
démenti tout à l'heure la correspondance
à moscou de vera goffman
moscou appelle qui avait respecté les
accords 2006 et la déclaration de la
porte-parole de la diplomatie russe
marya zakharova lors de son briefing
hebdomadaire
pour elle les négociations sur un
règlement pacifique de la crise je
craignais sont actuellement dans
l'impasse je vous propose d'écouter
spectrale la mine et howling rémy la
mission spéciale d'observation de l'osce
et eux constate le transfert d'armes
lourdes par kiev vers l'est du pays
notamment d'artillerie de gros calibre
et de véhicules blindés
l'utilisation de drones se poursuit
récemment l'union européenne s'est
jointe aux processus de militarisation
de l'ukraine le 2 décembre le conseil de
l'europe a décidé d'allouer 31 millions
d'euros pour une assistance technique
aux militaires à l'armée ukrainienne
cette décision ne contribuent en aucune
manière à la paix dans le bon bac n'est
ce pas s'abstenir audacia la situation
en ukraine a été discuté lors de la
rencontre par visioconférence entre le
président russe vladimir poutine et son
homologue américain joe biden le 7
décembre lors de ce sommet bilatéral
virtuel joe biden a fait savoir que
moscou s'exposerait à de fortes
sanctions entre autres économique en cas
d' escalade militaire autour de
l'ukraine selon un communiqué de la
maison blanche
moi ce qu a balayé à plusieurs reprises
les rumeurs sur des préparatifs
d'invasion de l'ukraine tout en
rappelant qu'elle prenait des mesures
pour assurer sa sécurité si nécessaire
le chef d'état major de l'armée russe
valery guirassy mof a dénoncé le noeud
décembre la multiplication des activités
de le temps aux frontières de la russie
a qualifié de mensonges les accusations
relayées dans les médias quant à la
prétendue volonté de mouscou d'envahir
le cren
un peu plus de cinquante six mille
nouveaux cas de kobe de 19 enregistrée
en france ces dernières 24 heures
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
prédit l'activation prochaine du plan
blanc pour tous les hôpitaux au niveau
national le dispositif est déjà déployée
dans cette région alors que le système
hospitalier du pays est en passe d'être
saturé thibault janin avec sébastien
savard
72 mille nouveaux cas en 24 heures un
malade qui entre en réanimation toutes
les 6 minutes c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
ministre de la santé ce matin est donnée
parmi les plus élevés depuis le début de
la pandémie la cinquième vague de kobe
19 poursuit sa progression et fait
désormais craindre une véritable tension
hospitalière pour anticiper une
éventuelle submersion plusieurs agences
régionales de santé ont décidé de
réactiver le plan blanc dans les
hôpitaux sont concernés la corse la
provence alpes côte d'azur la bourgogne
franche comté l'occitanie les pays de la
loire et l'île de france cette dernière
invite à la vigilance afin d'anticiper
la montée progressive du nombre de
patients covit 19 le déclenchement
généralisée de ces plans blancs donnent
la latitude aux directeurs
d'établissements en lien avec leurs
directeurs médicaux de crise de prendre
les mesures de gestion adaptés au niveau
local hôpital par hôpital par ailleurs
la rs ile de france tient à rappeler que
l'activation du plan blanc ne doit pas
conduire à renoncer aux soins et invite
tous les franciliens notamment les
personnes souffrant d'une maladie
chronique nécessitant une prise en
charge régulière à consulter en cas de
besoin une anticipation pour éviter une
nouvelle surchauffe notamment des
services de réanimation à la proche des
fêtes de fin d'année mais un plan blanc
qui n'est pas sans conséquence ce
dispositif entraîne la réduction de
l'activité hospitalière et la
possibilité de déprogrammer certaines
interventions moins prioritaires dans le
but d'augmenter les capacités de lits
pour les malades du coït 19 en soins
intensifs
un système de vases communicants qui
pourrait un peu plus mettre sous tension
un milieu hospitalier particulièrement
sollicités depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire et qui souffre de défection
des soignants depuis l'annnonce de
l'obligation vaccinale le gouvernement
lui se montre encore prudent
aujourd'hui la donne a changé et nous
tenons mieux face au virus nous avons
les moyens de protéger plutôt que d'en
fermer de prévenir plutôt que guérir et
nous les mettons pleinement en oeuvre
nous ne laisserons pas le virus gâcher
les fêtes nous avons fixé un cap clair
restrictions minimale et prudence
maximale nous sommes sur un chemin de
crête mais nous pouvons obtenir une
protection qui repose essentiellement
sur la vaccination plus de 11 millions
de personnes ont reçu une dose de rappel
et 15 millions supplémentaires devraient
suivre d'ici le début du mois de janvier
selon les prévisions gouvernementales
depuis l'incitation du gouvernement à
l'injection d'une troisième dose des
millions de français sont toujours dans
l'attenté d'une proposition de rendez
vous en face à cette cinquième vague le
gouvernement n'a de cesse d'appeler à la
vaccination pour accélérer la campagne
de rappel les pharmacies pourront ouvrir
les dimanches de décembre et de janvier
la vaccination qui sera accessible dès
le 20 décembre aux enfants les plus
fragiles âgées de 5 à 11 ans en
attendant ce matin le masque a fait son
retour à l'école dans les cours de
récréation
il n'était pas un été imposées jusqu'ici
que dans les espaces clos objectif
réduire les risques de contamination et
autres mesures anti qu'ovide prises par
l'exécutif lundi à partir de demain et
jusqu'au 6 janvier les discothèques qui
devront fermer leurs portes durant
quatre semaines il sera aussi interdit
de danser dans les bars et dans les
restaurants à un nouveau coup dur donc
pour les patrons de boîtes de nuit et
justement on en parle avec arthur est
mort saad directeur général de la folie
douce
bonsoir traverse ada vous êtes en direct
de bourg-saint-maurice merci de répondre
à nos questions
al'approche des vacances de noël vous
allez accueillir des vacanciers pour
noël ou encore pour le jour de l'an
après une année blanche ou presque dans
le quel état d'esprit ce que vous êtes
vous mais à la fois vos confrères que ce
soit à val d'isère à courchevel en
tarentaise ou encore à la toussuire ou à
valloire en maurienne
et bien vous reçoit effectivement
la saison ça pourrait être un petit peu
compliqué il faut déjà savoir que nous
avons fermé nos établissements il ya de
cela 18 mois et que nous n'avons jamais
rouvert nous avons recruté pour la
soigner douce mine de rien 600
saisonniers
qui sont aujourd'hui avec nous nous
préparons nos établissements mais avant
tout nous sommes des restaurateurs
passionné donc cette année ce sera la
restauration qui sera mis en avant et
non pas la partie festive de la folie
douce
le premier ministre a précisé que les
professionnels seraient accompagnés
connaît-il ce que est ce que c'est assez
qu'est ce que vous attendez exactement
on s'apprête vraiment à faire très très
attention avec avec le protocole
en tant que restaurateur je ne suis pas
sûr que l'on soit admise est à ce stade
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles on se
concentre vraiment sur nos exploitations
que les charges fixes des discothèques
fermaient à partir de vendredi seront
compensées à 100%
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles ne nous
concerne on
sait que manuel m'apprend était en
déplacement dans le cher récemment il a
déclaré ne vous sentez pas stigmatiser
ce n'est pas vrai vous êtes le seul
endroit où avec un pass and it erp vous
pouvez boire sans mettre le masque mais
on va essayer je m'y engage à rouvrir au
plus vite qu'est ce que vous en pensez à
ce que vous pensez que le 6 janvier vous
allait rouvrir ou es ce que vous avez
peur d'une nouvelle prolongation
c'est ce que je pense c'est qu'on doit
faire tous très très attention avec
cette crise sanitaire et
j'espère que cette parenthèse covit va
se refermer au plus tôt
nous concernant on demanderait surtout
avoir des domaines skiables et qui
deviendraient des covit freezone si je
peux dire en imposant le pass annie
terre au niveau des remontées mécaniques
en plus des restaurants d'altitude
aujourd'hui ce qui nous fait
relativement peur ce serait une
recrudescence de cas parce qu'il ya un
certain laxisme sur les domaines est ce
que par rapport à vous à la folie douce
ou vos confrères restaurateurs ou vos
confrères gérant de boîte de nuit est ce
que est ce que vous craignez des dépôts
de bilan est ce que vous avez peur pour
pour la fin de mois est pas et pour
payer également tous les tous les
saisonniers
est ce qu'il ya une hécatombe à attendre
c'est une c'est certes une catastrophe
dix-huit mois 18 mois de fermeture on ne
s'y attendait pas du tout
nous avons ouvert et comme je le disais
avec 600 collaborateurs 600
collaborateurs c'est une charge de
dingue elle permet mans de marchandises
qui est monté dans nos établissements de
produits frais les cuisines tourner
tambour battant
on ne pourrait pas se permettre de
refermer
ne pourrait pas se permettre
effectivement de ne pas faire une saison
complète cette année il ya une étude qui
est paru fin novembre l'étude comme
corps exactement menée par le professeur
en de fontanes et avec l'institut
pasteur qui est venu comme mois de
juillet dernier les soirées en boîte de
nuit ont fait grimper le risque de
contamination de sept cent
quatre-vingt-dix pour cent chez les
moins de 40 ans qu'elle passe sanitaires
les établissements de nuit reste un peu
un lieu à risque non
effectivement
concernant la montagne c'est le sujet
quand même ce soir la montagne ce sont
des lieux de plein air des lieux ouverts
et en l'occurrence donc la folie douce
des grandes terrasses très très grande
avec des grandes capacités d'accueil où
les clients seront toujours espacées et
c'est la raison aussi pour laquelle on
se focalise sur la restauration et non
pas sur la partie boîte de nuit
merci beaucoup arnaud art et versa
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes donc le directeur
général de la folie douce
les acteurs de sports d'hiver préoccupé
donc par les marchés financiers inquiets
également avant ce regain épidémique
avec
alors outre la recrudescence donc les
cadets le vario mikron fait peur aux
places boursières les dernières
nouvelles plutôt rassurantes sur le
virus ont entraîné un net rebond des
bourses mais pour combien de temps et
surtout qu'en est il des dommages pour
l'économie réelle à l'heure où l'europe
entière fait face à une résurgence du
comider où les restrictions se
multiplient est ce qu'on doit
s'inquiéter pour 2022 pas le place tout
de suite à l'édito de jacques sapir
[Musique]
la reprise de la pandémie qu'on constate
aujourd'hui en europe en europe est ce
qu'elle est de nature à compromettre la
croissance
oui bonjour grégory est ce qu'elle est
de nature à compromettre la croissance
s'est alors oui c'est une éventualité
qu'il faut avoir effectivement à
l'esprit parce que on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui elle a une nouvelle vague
il ya ce qu'on appelle la cinquième
vague que cette cinquième vague elle
commence à toucher toute une série de
pays il ya des pays qui ont repris des
mesures de confinement ou de quasi
confinement par exemple des couvre feux
et ça peut effectivement avoir un impact
de plus ou moins important sur la
croissance
jacques on enchaîne avec la reprise de
la pandémie qu'on constate aujourd'hui
en europe donc par rapport à faire
compromettre tout cela tout à fait et on
voit bien d'ailleurs que cette cinquième
vague elle a commencé plus tôt dans des
pays qui ne sont pas beaucoup vacciner 1
c'est les pays de l'europe de l'est la
bulgarie la roumanie de là elle a
progressé vers l'ouest elle a touché
l'autriche qui d'ailleurs est le premier
un pays à avoir re confiné elle touche
l'allemagne puis les pays-bas le
danemark et maintenant elle à elle toute
la france donc oui on voit bien
justement cette espèce de mouvement de
la pandémie et en même temps il faut
quand même dire que cette pandémie
n'apparaît pas aussi
désastreuse que les premières parce que
vous voyez on a là sur le graphique le
chiffre des contaminations je dis bien
des contaminations et effectivement les
contaminations sont actuellement plus
importante que ce qu'elle était pendant
toute l'année 2000 21 et même pendant
l'année 2020 mais le nombre de gens qui
sont en hospitalisation et encore plus
en réanimation reste toujours beaucoup
plus faible et concrètement comment
est-ce que ça soit lens sur l'europe
alors les conséquences si vous voulez
sont très liés aux mesures de
confinement ou de quasi confirmant comme
les couvre-feux on sait que chaque fois
qu'il ya un confinement ou
ou un néo confinement est bien sympa kt
à la fois les ménages qui consomment
beaucoup moins et ça impacte aussi très
nettement les entreprises et le problème
qui va se passer avec cette cinquième
vague c'est que on a déjà ce phénomène
mais on a en plus le fait que la
consommation des ménages n'est pas
revenu à son niveau de la fin de 2019
fois sombre au niveau globalement de
2019 elle a chuté brutalement en 2020
bien sûr qu'elle est repartie en 2021
mais elle tend à se stabiliser
actuellement plutôt au niveau de 2014
2015 et on le voit d'ailleurs sur le
graphique qui apparaît à l'écran et donc
ça c'est un sujet de préoccupation pour
tous les économies c'est ce que tout le
monde comprend que quand il ya moins de
consommation ya moins d'activités
économiques et comment ça s'explique
concrètement alors l'une des
explications c'est très certainement
l'importance de l'épargné accumulée
alors vous savez que l'épargné accumulée
là on voit aussi le graphique au niveau
de la zone euro bon elle a été
spectaculaire en 2020 alors pour la zone
euro c'est pour l'ensemble des pays on
est passés grosso modo de 14 % de taux
départ à 21 % du pipe de taux dépargne
en france et bien on a vu que pendant
les confinements c'était 165 milliards
d'euros qui avait été
épargnée ce que l'on sait peut-être un
petit peu moins c'est que en même temps
il y avait 30 % des ménages qui n'avait
pas épargné qui avait désigné c'est la
pression de la pauvreté et que cette
épargne elle est très concentré sur les
10 % les plus riches sur le dernier
décile qui à lui seul en a fait 130
milliards alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que les gens qui ont
surtout énormément épargnée ne sont pas
nécessairement très pressé de réinvestir
cet argent en dit long de leurs dépenses
et et on voit très bien ils ne peuvent
pas le dépenser actuellement les voyages
à l'étranger sont quand même très
restreint
il ya toute une série d'activités qui
commence à être restreinte si ce n'est
dans la loi du moins dans les faits par
exemple il ya beaucoup de restaurateurs
ou de gens qui organisent des événements
qui annonce des chutes de chiffre
d'affaires de 20 à 30% par rapport à ce
qu'il comptait faire pour noël donc il y
à bien aujourd'hui une forme de
contraction générale de la consommation
et de ce fait on va avoir une épargne
accumulée qui ne sert pas à grand chose
donc on a raison d'être inquiets pour la
croissance alors bien pour 2021 je ne
pense pas que ça aura beaucoup d'impact
est très sérieusement je pense que pour
2021 bon on fera peut-être pas les 6 7%
qui ont été prévu par l'insee mais on ne
devrait pas aller au delà d'un recul de
0 5% donc de passer à 1 6 2 % pour 2022
c'est un autre problème parce que même
si la france ne connaît pas de nouveaux
reconfirme ans et il ya toute une série
de raisons d'abord le fait qu'
évidemment avec le vaccin peut être
qu'on en aurait pas besoin et puis il ya
quand même une raison majeure c'est le
fait que nous allons avoir des élections
en 2022 donc même si la france ne
connaît pas de nouveau confinement et
bien si les confinements continuent de
se multiplier dans des pays voisins
autrement dit si l'activité des pays
voisins commencent à chuter de manière
importante par rapport à ces confinement
est d'ores et déjà on assiste à une
chute
de la production industrielle qui est
non négligeable en allemagne et ce qui
est encore plus important c'est une
chute de la demande alors elle est pour
l'instant plutôt moins forte dans les
pays de l'union européenne et la chute
la plus importante c'est au niveau de la
non union européenne autrement dit du
reste du monde néanmoins ça veut dire
que il y à bien d'autres mécanismes qui
sont aussi en oeuvre et oui
effectivement on peut avoir quelques
inquiétudes sur le taux de croissance
que l'on connaîtra en 2022 merci jacques
saint-pierre pour votre édito économique
y est la semaine prochaine ce sera votre
100e et dit tout à fait écho tout à fait
merci beaucoup
en tunisie un incendie s'est déclaré au
siège du parti ennahdha en plein coeur
de tunis après l'immolation par le feu
d'un partisan les pompiers et la police
sont intervenus dans l'après midi le feu
a été maîtrisé les premiers éléments de
l'enquêté font état d'un mort et de dix
huit blessés plus de précision avec la
correspondance de bassam subi hier à
tunis mais c'est ici en plein coeur de
tunis dans le quartier de montplaisir
qu'elle incendie s'est déclaré en début
d'après-midi ici dans le bâtiment juste
derrière moi le siège du parti ennahdha
un incendie qui s'est déclaré au
rez-de-chaussée qui a provoqué à être
des flammes qui se sont propagées sur
les différents étages du bâtiment
beaucoup de personnes étaient présentes
dans les lieux beaucoup de sympathisants
et adhérents du parti ennahda selon
certains témoins qui étaient sur place
de nombreuses personnes ont dû se
définissent tri pour pouvoir échapper
aux flammes plus de huit personnes ont
été transporté en urgence à l'hôpital
dont le vice président de parti du parti
monsieur ali el aryadh selon les
première source d'information qu'on a pu
avoir notamment celle d'un député
monsieur mohamed boumahni qui a affirmé
auprès de nos confrères de la radio
diwan que cet incendie était volontaire
et qui a été provoquée par un homme qui
s'est immolé par le feu cet homme est
décédé suite à ses blessures ennahda a
annoncé lors d'un communiqué qu'une
enquête sera ouverte pour déterminer les
causes exactes de cet incident le
président du parti ennahdha monsieur
rached ghannouchi à quitter les lieux
pour se rendre à l'hôpital auprès des
nombreux adhérents blessés ur en est cet
incendie est resté sur arte france on se
retrouve dans quelques instants avec le
focus sur la cascade de nom ce matin de
la part des candidats de la gauche à la
présidentielle
au lendemain de la proposition d'anne
hidalgo la candidate socialiste suggère
une primaire vers insoumis communistes
ne sont pas séduits restez avec nous et
réagissez sur le conte arte france de
télégrammes la gauche at-elle encore une
chance pour la prochaine présidentielle
a tout de suite
[Musique]
le long chemin de la réconciliation
nationale depuis deux décennies en côte
d'ivoire au moins le processus est il
sur le point de se concrétiser le
blocage véritable se situe au niveau des
hommes politiques plus de 3000 ivoiriens
en perdront la vie lors de la crise post
électorale de 2010 2011 avec beaucoup
d'attention ça tirait de partout c'était
s'était formé à l'as cozes et canton
soit et envoyait des traces de balles
principal envoyer des cadavres en moins
d'une semaine c'était c'était le chaos
après 2010 il y avait deux camps celui
des vainqueurs et des vaincus est-ce que
la situation s'est quand même amélioré à
ce niveau le chemin que la victime se
plaignent toujours le fait est que sur
le terrain les divisions existent où
joue le fait est que le climat politique
n'est pas encore véritablement apaisé
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si un
mort au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières à ce qu'il a toujours existé
où il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 noeuds même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre ou la
peuplent c'était une volonté collectés
vous le savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas noël ou blick
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
je
la nouvelle calédonie foule ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui à une mokaddem
les indépendantistes dans le paysage
politique en nouvelle calédonie qu il ya
une progression du oui le peuple
originel concernés par les dépendances
il l'indépendance field aventis au camp
représente la france pour la société
calédonienne il n'y a pas eu de n 1
roger de la france c'est à liège quand
même qu'il passa c'est-à-dire de
consumérisme d'assistanat ou ce que dit
j'ai un économiste une économie assistée
sous perfusion si on fait des
statistiques cruel pour trouver plus de
kanaks dans les prisons les hôpitaux
psychiatriques marche une société que
dans la réussite au niveau social
[Musique]
et
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct via quand même
la liberté je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité
[Musique]
de retour sur arte france il est 21h
très heureux de vous retrouver pour la
deuxième partie de l'émission est au
programme la kyrielle de nom ce matin de
la part du candidat de la gauche à la
présidentielle au lendemain de la
proposition d'anne hidalgo la candidate
socialiste suggère une primaire l'idée
ne séduit pas ses homologues écologistes
insoumis ou communistes et ce alors que
l'ensemble des candidats de gauche
réunit totalise seulement 25% des
intentions de vote dans les récents
sondages la gauche at-elle encore une
chance pour avril prochain on attend vos
retours sur le télégramme verte et
france
[Musique]
l'union de la gauche de nouveau au
centre des débats la maire de paris est
candidate socialiste à la présidentielle
a l'hidalgo a proposé hier soir donc une
primaire qui ont refusé ce matin
insoumis communistes et écologistes
on trouve tout de suite et unis google
en direct de l'hôtel de ville de paris
et me dit la maire de paris anne hidalgo
est en ce moment même sur le plateau de
nos confrères de lci pour répondre à ces
refus en cascade et pour s'exprimer sur
la suite qu'elle entend donner à sa
campagne en tout cas le rejet de sa
proposition d'une primaire de la gauche
a été assez brutales
weegee gorille le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que sa proposition n'a pas
convaincu on ne voit vraiment pas
comment sa proposition pourrait même se
concrétiser les réactions des candidats
de gauche sont claires à en croire tout
d'abord l'entourage de jean luc
mélenchon pour la france insoumise
entourage qui raillent anne hidalgo
rappelant que ce mercredi matin sur
france télévisions elle disait au
contraire qu'une union de la gauche
seraient perçus comme artificiels et que
ça ne fonctionnerait pas jean-luc
mélenchon qui a finalement pas reprendre
directement la parole tout à l'heure
pour indiquer qu'il aurait que sa
proposition respirer l'improvisation et
qu'elle était même ridicule autre
réaction par dont celle des communistes
et c'est également un refus l'entourage
du candidat fabien roussel estime que la
gauche ne parle plus aux classes
populaires et puis ce matin yannick
jadot le candidat europe ecologie les
verts a lui aussi opposé une fin de
non-recevoir anne hidalgo il estime que
la candidate socialiste a lancé cet
appel à une primaire populaire parce que
sa candidature ne suscite tout
simplement pas d'intérêt de la part des
électeurs écoutez
j'ai écouté anne hidalgo et elle prend
acte de l'impasse de sa candidature et
du fait que les idées qu'elles portent
peine à percer dans l'opinion publique
il y a une volonté de sortir de
l'impasse par une idée surprise en tout
cas ce n'est pas le choix des
écologistes quoi qu'il arrive je ne
participerai pas une primaire de la
gauche l'élection présidentielle et dans
quatre mois et demi et il faut être un
peu sérieux
en revanche grégory s'il rejette la
primaire yannick jadot fabien roussel et
jean luc mélenchon veulent chacun
apparaître comme le candidat de la
gauche et appelle les électeurs à
soutenir leurs programmes et me dit
alors pourquoi une telle proposition de
la part d'anne hidalgo
eh bien grégory parce qu'elles
considèrent que la gauche est fracturée
et qu'elle n'a pas d'autre choix que de
se rassembler la maire de paris
n'obtiendrait que trois voire 7% des
intentions de vote selon les derniers
sondages quant aux autres candidats de
gauche ils sont aussi à la peine avec
moins de 10% des intentions de vote
conséquence anne hidalgo a tout de même
reçu quelques soutiens pour sa primaire
arnaud montebourg avec son parti la
remonte tada il s'est dit prêt à offrir
sa candidature à un projet commun et à
un candidat commun regarder également ce
tweet d'olivier fort le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
il détourne à un même du rappeur
américain drake pour critiquer la
position des autres candidats de gauche
pour olivier faur rejeté l'appel d'anne
hidalgo reviendrait à laisser le champ
libre à la droite mais aussi à l'extrême
droite la proposition d'une primaire à
gauche a donc un intérêt stratégique et
grâce à anne hidalgo
peut-être grâce à grâce à elle elle peut
se présenter comme comme une sorte de
candidates rassembleuse et aussi se
donner l'image de la candidate de
l'union
merci emilie goog h pour toutes ces
précisions directeur de route de l'hôtel
de ville de paris alors comment la
gauche peut-elle rassemblé une primaire
à une bonne ou une mauvaise idée la
gauche at-elle encore une chance pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 on attend vos
réactions sur télégramme tout de suite
place au débat
[Musique]
et sur ce plateau eric revel
éditorialiste politique bonsoir vous
êtes accompagné de renier brunet guy
bonsoir vous êtes membre de l'équipe de
campagne d'arnaud montebourg et donc de
la remontée haddad la france et puis on
skype avec nous guillaume kashi
porte-parole de fabien roussel candidat
du parti communiste français à la
présidentielle et directeur également de
publication de la revue cause commune
bonsoir à tous et merci d'être avec nous
renier brunet guy arnaud montebourg
avait appelé avant hidalgo à l'union l'a
vu avec ml google force est de constater
que pour l'instant cette union ça n'a
pas l'air de prendre en tous les cas est
la fille élevée et pcf n'en veulent pas
est-ce que l'union est ce qu'elle est
toujours possible anne hidalgo ce soir
elle a dit ça ce soir s'il n'y a pas de
rassemblement de la gauche il n'y a pas
de gauche au second tour c'est vrai
c'est vrai leur entièrement raison je ne
vois pas aujourd'hui comment la gauche
peut gagner en étant autant divisée et
je crois aussi que pour les primaires en
tout cas la proposition linda legault a
le mérite d'exister d'être porte dans le
débat public health en est une mais en
tout cas c'est pas ça qu'on privilégie
aujourd'hui on le sait que organiser une
primaire c'est dans un laps de temps
aussi court ça paraît déjà pris un moins
extrêmement compliqué et qu'aujourd'hui
avant de choisir une personne il faut se
mettre d'accord sur un programme commun
aujourd'hui on le voit ya des points de
convergence ici point de divergence il
faut se mettre autour de la table et
négocier tout simplement il faut
négocier ce qui est possible ensemble
négocier les points de divergence et
ensuite on choisira un candidat
potentiel ma semaine autour de la table
ça tombe bien puisque guillaume kashi
est là également il n'est pas
physiquement la haute mais il est quand
même là guillaume cachiez donc fabien
roussel ce matin sur france info hésité
à employer le mot non
pour dit-il dire oui aux français et
pour être le président de tous les
français et pour rassembler mais comment
rassembler quand il n'est crédité que de
2% des intentions de vote et 2 et demi
pour cent pour arnaud montebourg
en fait si vous voulez ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que nous avons proposé nous
un pacte d'engagement commun depuis le
départ notamment en vue des élections
législatives qui permettent davantage le
rassemblement et puis en rappelant que
les élections législatives sont les
élections déterminantes si vous voulez
dans le cadre même dans le cadre de la
5ème république avec par le monde a
baissé pour l'instant je voudrais
s'achèveront de passer à la troisième mi
temps il ya quand même le premier tour
est le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle qui sont véritablement
comme le premier match avant de penser
au deuxième
j'entends bien mais en l'occurrence pour
ce qui est des élections présidentielles
vous voyez bien une difficulté pourquoi
la gauche si faible c'est pas parce
qu'elle est divisée elle est si faible
parce que bien une partie notre pays n'a
pas confiance en elle et on comprend
pourquoi parce que l'expérience qui a
rassemblé les socialistes et des
écologistes à dire fois elle était
désastreuse regardez l'extrême droite
par exemple extrême droite ils ont
quatre candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ça les empêche pas de
faire des scores tout à fait
considérable donc je pense c'est une
réponse qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
problèmes la réponse que la gauche tout
apporté c'est de répondre aux
préoccupations des français aujourd'hui
eh bien on voit bien que tu rassembles
de questions importantes ou le temps
notamment le rapport vient au traité
européen allemand et ça on devrait être
d'accord avec le camp dit le
représentant de l'équipe de thé d'arnaud
montebourg là on voit bien que c'est pas
en continuant à en remettre une pièce
the jukebox là on réussira à mobiliser
eric revel quand on comptabilise tous
les candidats de la gauche en arrive
selon les dernier un sondage à 25%
environ comment est-ce que ça s'explique
est ce que c'est une désaffection des
français pour les de l'idée gauche
d'abord il n'ya pas une gauche mais il
ya plusieurs gauches donc rassemblé
plusieurs gauches sous une même bannière
c'est déjà la quadrature du cercle
manuel valls a eu cette formule les
gauches irréconciliables mais c'est vrai
que quand on écoute le représentant du
parti communiste représentant d'arnaud
montebourg les représentants ou à nidal
bourg voit bien qu'ils sont pas du tout
sur la migros dombes mais au delà du
rassemblement à l'époque il avait la
gauche plurielle quand il joue quand
même excellent programme commun alors ça
c'est pas d'une modernité absolue parce
que à l'époque les communistes faisait
équipe avec françois mitterrand georges
marchais robert fabre et on voit ce que
ça a permis aux communistes de la
manière dont ils sont effondrés
d'ailleurs après le programme commun de
80 83 mais je voudrais dire une chose
c'est qu'aujourd'hui au delà de la
question du rassemblement il ya quelque
chose de beaucoup plus central pourquoi
est-ce que l'électorat populaire a fui
le parti communiste pour leur assemblée
nationale pourquoi est ce que les
françaises et les français
majoritairement on verra les résultats
de l'élection ne croient plus en la
gauche mais en fait parce que la gauche
a porté pendant des années des années et
des années dans les années 80 90 des
idées sociétal qui modifiait l'évolution
la société française et que depuis ces
années 90 la gauche est en panne d'idées
elle ne propose plus aux classes les
plus défavorisées elle ne parle plus
assez classe là et aujourd'hui je le
disais tout à l'heure vous avez l'effet
inverse la gauche proposé des idées dans
les années 90 et en réaction la droite
réagissait aux idées de la gauche et
donc les réactionnaires c'étaient les
jambes droites et bien si je force un
peu le trait dirait qu'il se passe
exactement le contraire aujourd'hui
c'est que ce sont les idées de droite ou
de droite nationale qui sont sur le
sommet de la table et la gauche est en
réaction aux idées qui sont sur la table
et qui font le débat politique c'est sa
toute la faillite de la gauche
aujourd'hui et je pousse un peu plus à
caricaturer jeudi comme la gauche est en
réaction aux idées qui qui qui
aujourd'hui sont en débat dans le sur la
présidentielle les nouveaux
réactionnaires ce sont les gens de
gauche en réalité parce qu'ils n'ont
plus d'autre choix que de réagir
aux idées qui sont portées par la droite
et ses salles inversement il ne parle
plus aux classes populaires je vous
propose de réagir messieurs à ce qu'a
écrit pascal des sur le compte arte
france de télégrammes la gauche existe
toujours ce sont les politiciens étant
reconnu comme étant de gauche par le
peuple de gauche qui n'existe plus vos
réactions je commence avec avec vous
guillaume cacher ou à l'egypte après
dans les emails deuxième par là
guillaume
givet allez-y la gauche à mes yeux oui
existe toujours sauf que quand vous
voyez par exemple
en effet il ya plusieurs gauches ça
c'est clair on le voit et c'est
difficile de se mettre tout le monde met
tout le monde d'accord autour de la
table mais il faut le faire je crois il
faut le faire et on a des points de
convergence certains entre les
différentes personnes entre les
différents candidats en tout cas mais
aujourd'hui on parle surtout de
divergences à chaque fois on dit je ne
suis pas d'accord sur ceux ci une super
accord sur cela mettons d'abord de
convergence ensemble et ensuite on verra
ce qu'on peut faire
je crois une chose comme qui est
extrêmement importante c'est qu'avant
même de parler
d'autres sujets de personnes il faut
qu'on montre probable des points de
convergence entre nous et on doit
rassembler en tout cas cette gauche là
ça c'est clair on est obligé de le faire
et après peut-être que on verra le
résultat ensuite mais en tout cas on est
obligé de commencer par là d'avoir
comment dire une candidature moins de
candidatures en tout cas à gauche ça
c'est clair guillaume cachiez renier
brunet gay vous a tendu la main vous
l'apprenez
c'est pas si longtemps la main en tout
cas moi je suis d'accord pour tendre la
main pour prendre un chemin à une autre
occasion peut-être mais pas sur la
question des primaires parce que c'est
comme comme fabien roussel ce matin je
ne vais pas dire non il vous dit pas non
vous dites un nom un petit peu
dans la balance d'arnaud montebourg en
disant on est prêt à se retirer ce n'est
pas en disant on se rejoignent et nous
comme trop souvent on entend ça en
disant ok on met le toit nature en
retrait pour parlons de nos convergences
et ensuite mais la force à force de dire
tout le temps ça est ça qui sera le
principal responsable de la division
non mais écoutez il faut on arrête de
parler de ce titre de division en
permanence comme si l'union avait une
capacité propulsive aujourd'hui des gens
ils cherchent des cohérences et des
réponses à leurs problèmes qui ont fait
une espèce de boughezoul gars est un
truc politiciens qui se voit comme le
nez au milieu de la figure avec des gens
qui ne pensent pas la même chose en
disant voté pour nous et vous verrez
bien ce que ça donne ça ne donnera rien
ça n'est pas possible la politique ce
n'est pas cela et puis excusez moi
essayons nous rappeler au monde du front
populaire c'est quoi le front populaire
tu es un moment où effectivement
l'extrême droite est très forte et
qu'est ce qu'on fait eh bien il ya des
rapprochements mais au premier tour
chacun se présenter au deuxième tour on
soutient celui qui est le mieux placé et
en même temps on avance avec les peuples
campagnes politiques aux décharges
encore faudra t il candidat écolo ce
qu'ils puissent accéder au deuxième tour
et pour le moment c'est pas le cas
j'entends bien mais c'est pas en mettant
des gens c'est pas en mettant ensemble
des gens sur le champ sans contenu très
arrêtées qu'on réussira la nasa n'aura
pas de côté propulsif n'aura pas de côté
pour attirer des gens aujourd'hui ce que
l'on dit c'est déjà mettons nous autour
de la table tout simplement déjà 10 lors
des deux soirées ça se trouve rien qui
en sortira il ya un site qui s'appelle
la primaire populaire une association
qui veut créer une primaire qui pour
l'instant n'existe pas est ce que vous
seriez prêt à y participer
alors ça je laisse le candidat y
répondre en tout cas à ce qui est clair
c'est qu'aujourd'hui une primaire on
n'est pas forcément favorable à cela
aujourd'hui avant même de parler de
choix de personnes il faut parler déjà
de convergence de programme il s'est
juste fidal de dire on choisit quelqu'un
avec un programme qui est rétabli menti
mais pas d'accord à la fin on sait que
ça ne marche pas arnaud montebourg a été
le premier à proposer les primaires en
france en tout cas il a écrit un rapport
sur le sujet en 2009
il a été précurseur il a entre
guillemets poussé à ceux appliqués en
france aujourd'hui on voit les limites
de l'exercice dans un régime qui est
entre guillemets tripartite ça marche
bien un régime qui est bi partie
aujourd'hui les limites de l'exercice
aujourd'hui en france en tout cas et
d'un prenons acte c'est le mérite
d'exister les primaires c'est pas le
meilleur en tout cas maintenant on est
prêt à étudier tout ce qui est possible
non en tout cas étudions parle on
échange on et ça se trouve il y aura
cinq candidatures à gauche à la fin en
avril peut-être on n'en sait rien mais
en tout cas mettons nous d'accord avant
et discutons et est ce qu'il pourrait y
avoir une candidature
christiane taubira et oui j'avais vous
en parler pour une raison très simple
alors je prends tu viens juste juste
avant elle eric revel juste un mode anne
hidalgo qui a parlé injustement ce soir
de madame taubira en disant j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié pour elle mais j'ai
encore pas parler avec elle voilà on y
allait très bien bompard fait franc je
sais pas comment les liens le jeu
j'essaie de raisonner un peu froidement
un évidemment je ne prends pas parti
j'essaie d'avoir une vision un peu
global bon je comprends très bien le
besoin de programmes avant de se mettre
d'accord sur des noms tout ça est très
juste et d'ailleurs c'est l'honneur de
la politique de proposer aux électeurs
des programmes sur lequel ils vont voter
plutôt que qu'une incarnation forte ou
pas mais je vous ferai remarquer une
chose c'est que le point commun de ces
deux campagnes présidentielles me
semble-t-il que ce soit à gauche ou à
droite ou chez les écologistes
la vraie nouveauté c'est la radicalité
c'est le mot a dit call à droite je fais
pas de dessin la radicalité elle
s'affichait les hôtes dans les sondages
chez les verts madame rousseau a failli
l'emporter alors qu'elle est arrivé de
nulle part sur un programme certes mais
sur un positionnement
radical pour les écologistes monsieur
roussel chez madame hidalgo essayer de
trouver un des minutes dénominateur chez
vous qui incarnerait aux yeux des
français du peuple de gauche la
radicalité et j'envoie une justement
j'en vois une qui s'appelle madame
taubira parce que précisément madame
taubira elle ferait plaisir au parti
communiste en piquant des voix à jean
luc mélenchon ce qui déplairait pas la
place du colonel fabien arnaud
montebourg je pense il a de bonnes
relations avec madame taubira madame
hidalgo la connais depuis longtemps elle
a peut incarner cette radicalité
aujourd'hui je pense qu'au delà du
programme il faut un candidat de gauche
qui incarne une radicalité à gauche si
c'est quelque chose d'un peu un peu un
peu mou un peu tiède et bien ça ne
prendra pas quel que soit le programme
donc peut-être que madame taubira oui
justement peut-être et je pense que pour
jean luc mélenchon ce serait sans doute
la pire des nouvelles que d'avoir une
candidate comme cela qu'ils
incarneraient la gauche alors par le
parti communiste mais qui incarnerait le
parti socialiste parce qu'elle pourrait
ratisser assez large dans son camp
évidemment il s'agit pas de dire qu'on
aime taubira sera au second tour il
serait utile serait il s'agirait de dire
que madame taubira et éviterait
peut-être une claque magistrale à la
gauche en affichant non plus souhaité
plus un mais en affichant un score
raisonnable a régné brunet guillet est
ce que vous vous ralliez riez du côté de
l'ars montana avec arnaud montebourg à
christiane taubira écoutez il faut
échanger il faut il faut discuter je
n'en sais rien en tout cas de ce qui est
sur la table aujourd'hui on n'a pas
échangé récemment et madame taubira ça
fait quelques mois il me semble qu'elle
réfléchit à cette possibilité écoutez
discutons-en moment venu avec toutes les
personnes qui souhaitent construire un
programme ensemble à gauche
même question pour voguer me cacher
nous on n'est pas dans l'idée de se
retirer vis-à-vis de madame taubira dans
la mesure où de borély date et nous bien
sûr c'est une personnalité de gauche que
nous avons n'est pas une position
sectaire et évidemment ce qu'est la fed
en matière de mariage pour tous et pour
nous quelque chose de très positif et
donc il n'y a pas de problème mais en
revanche quel est son programme en
matière économique et sociale on ne peut
pas se rallier comme ça une personnalité
juste parce qu'on aime bien et par un
échec tant qu'elle a pu mener entre
communistes de la justice
une jamin vous montrer une réaction de
bénéfique sur sur télégramme les partis
ne servent qu'à diviser les français il
son pseudo sur la pseudo opposition et
la crise actuelle l'a démontré la gauche
comme la droite
sur définitivement morte est ce que vous
comprenez les téléspectateurs qui en
sera de même en faut je pense que on a
besoin au contraire on a besoin d'un
affrontement démocratique gauche droite
dans ce pays on a cru pouvoir s'en
passer en tout cas les français qui ont
voté pour emmanuel macron ont cru
pouvoir s'en passer avec le en même
temps moi je prétends qu'au contraire il
faut de vraies lignes de fracture
politique il faut opposer des programmes
il faut débattre démocratiquement
de rassembler la gauche mais quand on
rassemble forcément à faire des
consensus non non non mais moi je prends
moi je parle de gauche républicaine et
de droite républicaine je pense que ce
clivage qui a beaucoup déçus eux aussi
les français c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
tournés vers d'autres partis mais ce
clivage là entre une gauche
héritière de jaurès du front populaire
et une droite républicaine
plus gaulliste autre chose c'est
extrêmement important pour le pays
surtout dans le contexte qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui de de violences et
d'affrontements bon je ne sais pas si
emmanuel macron sera réélu évidemment
s'il sera au second tour extra mais je
pense que la disparition de ce clivage
qui était quand même le moteur principal
démocratie française pendant des
décennies il faut absolument pas qu'on
le conte le conte le conte le gone qu'on
le raye il faut absolument pas que les
partis traditionnels disparaissent au
profit de trucs qui représente pas grand
chose finalement parce qu'on a besoin
dans un pays démocratique
d'affrontements idéologiques de débat
projet contre projet plus qu'un individu
si on l'a pas eh bien on est dans cette
pièce de situations où la violence ne
cesse de monter parce que précisément il
ya plus d'exutoire politique le en même
temps c'est pas c'est pas un driver
politique c'est une posture marketing
c'est bon pour le représentant de la
start up nation mais c'est pas ça qui
structurent un débat démocratique parce
que vous êtes la médiation entièrement
d'accord et quand on regarde la gauche
morcelée est ce qu'au final ce ne sont
pas les égaux des candidats qui prennent
le pas sur les idéologies en elle-même
au mambourg a pas d'ego ça se saurait
cette dure non non il a il est râpeux il
a il a quand même
de lego comme tout à chacun
néanmoins néanmoins aujourd'hui il il a
mis sa correction dans la balance c'est
le premier à le faire voilà en disant
très clairement il est prêt à se retirer
pour quelque chose pour un projet commun
donc donc on fait le premier pas en
temps une main par contre s'il n'ya rien
s'il n'y a personne comment dire qu'ils
souhaitent construire ensemble eh ben on
ira et on ira jusqu'au bout c'est simple
que cela voilà et je reviens en tout cas
sur les propos de monsieur je crois
qu'en effet on a besoin d'affrontements
idéologiques il faut échanger il faut
débattre entre gauche droite on peut
débattre aussi l'intérieur de la gauche
si ses seins en tout cas et il faut 7
c'est ce débat pour être une forme de
soupape de sécurité en tout cas dans le
débat public regardez comment regarder
comment fabien roussel j'aimerais
peut-être avoir votre votre point de vue
comment fabien roussel s'est décalé sur
sa droite en matière de sécurité
en france est absolument vers fable
samassa m'a frappé c'est à dire qu'avant
le parti communiste était plus du côté
du peuple guillaume cacher un
championnat il va pas être d'accord et
moi je lui des déclarations de monsieur
roussel joue j'étais extrêmement étonné
de voir devoir de voir le parti
communiste prendre cet axe là je ne le
comptage pas du tout cas je constate
game cash et non non non non parce que
justement pourquoi est ce que la gauche
on est là aujourd'hui mais peut-être
aussi parce que à un moment elle a
commencé à renoncer à s'occuper des
préoccupations populaires et parmi les
préoccupations populaires et notamment
dans les milieux populaires il faut bien
le dire et vous savez contre l'iniquité
des pages on a le nez pas le thème parce
que le rassemblement national avait
avait mis la main sur ce thème donc tous
les paris perd ça suffit mais oui bien
sage et ça c'est assez serrée d'alors et
celle que j'aimerais que vous répondiez
après à ma question également sur le
fait est ce que les égos prennent le pas
sur l'idéologie quand aucun candidat ne
serait être retiré sa candidature et
qu'au final
voilà 25% réunis je veux dire une chose
très rare je vais vous répondre mais
juste ni le 9 décembre aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire de loi de 1905 la laïcité
un moment elle a été kidnappée par le
front national kidnappé est absolument
dévoyé et bien non nous nous faisions ça
suffise de ce hold-up lamentable lèvera
défenseurs de la laïcité c'est bien sûr
une valeur de jaurès et les valeurs de
la gauche et nous nous portons
aujourd'hui cette valeur et tant pis si
les autres et bien on en faire un
kidnapping lamentable sur la question
des ego je dois reconnaître que moi ça
m'insupporte parce que c'est vraiment
pas une question d'ego qu'est ce que
c'est que c'est toi c'est une question
de débat politique il ya des gaziers des
projets pour la france qui ne sont pas
les mêmes ça n'a rien à voir avec des
égos des uns et des autres qu'est ce
qu'on va faire en matière économique
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on va relever le
pays on se doit sur dotant des moyens
est ce qu'on va par exemple nationaliser
la société générale lâche analyse et axa
pour pouvoir donner à l'état les moyens
d'intervenir pour répondre aux besoins
des français et relancer le pays sur des
questions importantes voilà ça n'a rien
à voir avec des questions d'ego quel
projet ont nourri pour l'éducation
nationale est-ce qu'on va recruter des
dizaines de milliers d'enseignants par
rapport à ça où est ce qu'on va laisser
filer pour l'europe parce qu'on va aller
vers l'europe fédérale où est ce qu'on
va travailler au développement d'une
souveraineté populaire bon voilà c'est
des questions qui n'ont rien volé à la
fin les 3l de dioula la question des ego
c'est aussi une question d'argent parce
que si vous n'avez pas de candidats qui
se présentent derrière vous avez du mal
à avoir des députés et si vous n'avez
pas de députés derrière vous avez du mal
à alimenter la caisse de votre parti il
ya aussi cette question là et chacun
diallo ne touche pas au grisbi parce que
c'est aussi une question d'argent il
faut financer les partis politiques
il ya une aide de l'état mais il y aussi
ce que les députés reverse à chacun de
leur parti si vous n'êtes pas de
candidat ben là c'est compliqué d'avoir
des députés et c'est le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup et eric revel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci à vous
deux guillaume cachiez d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole de fabien roussel candidat
pcf à la présidentielle et directeur de
publication de la revue cause commune
merci également à vous régnez à brunet
guillet vous êtes membre de l'équipe de
campagne d'arnaud montebourg et de la
roma voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi rendez vous lundi
dès 20h et d'ici là n'oubliez pas de
réagir de commenter et de poser vos
questions sur le télégramme d'ayrté
france pro champions sur la cub dans une
trentaine de minutes avec pierre pissavy
yvernault très bonne soirée à toutes et
à tous ma mère
[Musique]
un des freins à priori du nucléaire
c'est l'émergence dé nouvelles sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui nous sommes le
pays qui produit l'électricité la plus
décarbonés au monde on peut rêver à
couvrir toute la planète de d'éoliennes
mais qu'on s'a produit un tiers du temps
que fait-on pour le reste 1 puis il ya
aussi la démographie ils en sont
toujours à l'afrique quand même avec un
milliard d'habitants plus la surface de
l'afrique ne soit pas suffisante pour
mettre des panneaux solaires ou sinon ça
se fera au détriment de l'agriculture on
joue aux apprentis sorciers y compris au
niveau européen quand un pays comme
l'allemagne décide du lourd lendemain
d'arrêter le nucléaire trouvera les
centrales à charbon l'allemagne est le
plus gros pollueurs européens
aujourd'hui le djia qui a sonné l'alarmé
sur les